so is
dopamine the only driving force in
why we seek to accomplish something i
would say it is the primary driving
force dopamine is
the molecule that is creating motivation
craving and drive for things that are
outside our immediate possession or
experience beyond the confines of our
skin so seeking new relationships
seeking a new uh item that you want to
buy seeking a degree seeking a win
seeking a trophy okay seeking but
there's another set of rewards that have
to do with the feelings of pleasure that
we derive from things that we already
have that we experience this very
intensely around close relationships
with people or animals that we feel
kinship with you don't need to seek them
they're just there just feels good
[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today is definitely pretty intense today
on the show is andrew huberman he is a
neuroscientist a tenured professor at
stanford university he has an incredible
podcast called the hubermann lab podcast
in which i've listened to so many
episodes of because
maybe you guys have gotten the flow of
this but i basically get really
fascinated with somebody and then i see
if they'll do my show and allow me the
opportunity to ask so many questions
that pop up for me when i listen to them
and andrew is just so brilliant so
fascinating dopamine was the first
really big topic we talked about we
talked about the system of it and how
that works within the body why we do
things and why why we're motivated why
we're not and then also the importance
of that rhythm then we kind of parlayed
into relationships and how dopamine
plays into relationships and what
creates connection and why we choose the
partners we choose as well as grief and
when there's law endings whether it's a
relationship or even you know
a maybe a loss of a life but we talked a
little bit about grief and and the
difference between grief and depression
i think we spent the first 40 minutes
talking about stuff that i had no idea
we'd talk about so i hope you enjoy the
flow of this conversation uh if you like
the show please hit the subscribe the
bell for notifications of when we have
another show come out and leave some
comments below about what you think
i love that you have a magnifying glass
over your shoulder in the background on
the shelf yeah it looks like one of
those magnifying glasses
yeah that's an actually an antique uh
zeiss microscope i i have a bit of a
microscope thing i i love microscopes
and i love the history of microscopes
and so that's one that
i forget where i got that i think i got
that there's a little store in santa
monica um
oh and the name escapes oh it's called
jadis props i have no affiliation to
them but it's a store that i think
started off as doing um
props for film
and so they have space suits and
microscopes and all this nerdy stuff and
i walked in there thinking this was a
normal store because that's normal for
me
and i realized that this was
for movies but they're very nice people
there and so everyone's a while i'll
drop in there and they have beautifully
restored microscopes and that that's one
of them
what is it about microscopes i'm curious
that's an interesting fondness
yeah um well we may get into this today
in terms of um
uh practical tools but basically
what's interesting about microscopes to
me is there have two main obsessions in
life i mean i have actually i have many
obsessions
the joke in my lab is i have about 3 500
obsessions and about 3 500 pet peeves
and they don't map one but one of my
obsessions is time perception and the
other one is space perception so i find
it amazing that you know we can
expand our visual aperture and take in
tons of information and experience life
through this enormous aperture right
panoramic vision um
as you know
far better than i'm moving through space
while perceiving objects around us or we
can narrow that visual aperture very
rapidly to resolve detail
and
and that fascinates me because it it
speaks to the the sort of scale and
scope of of human experience right
and then in parallel to that i i have an
obsession with time perception which is
that we can batch time in big bins like
if you go on vacation and you're laying
out on the beach all day like the day
just kind of feels like it goes by and
yet you saw batching time in these big
windows or in moments of
very high alertness or stress or or
excitement positive
arousal we start to find slice time at
you know
the equivalent of thousand frames per
second we've all experienced this where
um you have a day where you just go and
do so many things and it feels like the
day just flew by and you look back so
much happened whereas if you go to the
doctor's office and you're waiting in
the waiting room it feels like it takes
forever and when you look back nothing
happened and that the visual aperture
and the
time aperture
actually scale with one another and in
some interesting ways and we understand
a little bit about the mechanisms of
that but
um when people talk about things like
flow states yeah or
um flow has a very specific name as it
relates to learning of skills and this
is the famous work of the psychologist
cheeks them high when something is just
beyond our skill level and we're
reaching and reaching and we're making
tangible progress that he described as
flow but
flow i believe also relates to this
incredible experience of when our time
and space perception is ideally matched
to the thing we need to perform
it becomes it feels very seamless you've
probably experienced this driving right
where all of a sudden
clearly it's you driving the car but
you're not in the mode of having to make
decisions
of course you're making decisions but
what's happening in that state is that
you are not perceived you're um
perceiving time and space in a way that
you're not actually perceiving your own
decision making process you're moving
faster than that
your
um your your motor movements are um
precisely time to the needs of and the
dynamics of the cars around you in the
race right tied to your inner narrative
and so it's not quick enough the inner
narrative's not quick enough that's
right so this can get a little abstract
but the short answer is um i like
microscopes because
down the microscope you you can resolve
immense detail it's like a whole other
universe there right you look at
anything under a microscope is pretty
interesting
yeah
is it a different universe though or is
it or i'm kind of fascinated with the
idea of fractals
and how
our reality
can again be under a microscope zoom
down and be similar of course you don't
see little people walking but
maybe it's
something biological maybe it's bacteria
i don't know and then when you look from
a macro level
also things can have similar patterns
what do you think about when you think
about that obsession or that curiosity
is there a question you ask yourself
when it comes to
um the microscope the micro macro and
the time like what are the questions you
actually are seeking perhaps
yeah well you you um make the important
point exactly which is that there's a
um
there's a build up of
anything and everything from
the same component parts right i mean
you know protons and electrons and atoms
we all know that um
but in terms of the and
in terms of how we build up a kind of
what we call neuroscience a hierarchical
structure i'll explain what i mean by
that just briefly when you look at
anything like a face
or a car
the perception of that thing is built up
from very basic filters and elements
that exist in the eye and elsewhere in
the brain that basically take the visual
scene around you and break it up into
dark lines and light lines
and moving things and the direction
they're moving
and then creates these
perceptions really that this best guess
about what's out there so since if i
draw two dots on a piece of paper and a
line right below it and i show it to you
you will get a slight sense that that's
a face
right but if i were to draw the line
vertical
in less so and if i were to draw the
line you know um
uh curved and off to the side you would
never think that was a face what that
tells us is that our perception of faces
is built up from these basic component
parts and indeed it is so there's this
kind of what's called a hierarchical
models and this is how we perceive
everything um
everything um so a song has its
component parts of tones and etc
so when i look down the microscope you
know
there's an ability to for us to shrink
our perception into that narrow space
and time domain and to kind of get lost
in it but what's remarkable about the
human experience and actually what's
remarkable about being human
and we don't think other animals have
this although we don't know for sure
is that we can deliberately expand or
contract
our space and time perception i can make
the decision to be in this zoom and and
narrowly focused i can make the decision
to expand my thoughts i can um and you
know nowadays there are people talk a
lot about adhd and add some of which is
clinically valid attention deficit
disorders some of which is just kind of
being distracted we are having a harder
time nowadays because of the number of
things pulling us out of this what kind
of tunnel of focus that said i think
that human beings have evolved and
thrived on
largely on their basis of
people's willingness to stay in a narrow
aperture of experience so learning to
drive a race car and then to race at the
level that you have and to do other
things that you've done requires a
either a love of
and or a dedication to being in a pretty
narrow aperture set of experiences right
right and to not like actually it's
funny i can talk about that but that's
exactly right
yeah and i think that inside of those
narrow apertures are
we create new milestones and rewards and
this gets it speaks to the kind of the
reward systems of the brain are pretty
generic um they relate to dopamine and
serotonin mainly mostly dopamine um
dopamine is this incredible
neurochemical that makes us feel
motivated and in a state of craving and
drive when you think about when you're
in a narrow aperture of say
pursuing a school degree or
pursuing a win in a race i mean it's as
if this system which is indeed very
generic dopamine you're now saying okay
the currency of reward is not the dollar
or the bitcoin or the euro it's dopamine
and i'm gonna
superimpose that
on to this narrow aperture of experience
now you finish that
and then the you a healthy person says
um a healthy athlete or student or
physician whatever says um okay now i'm
gonna make the dopamine about the
healthy relationships of my life or that
my health my bodily health the unhealthy
entrepreneur
parent
athlete etc had can only derive dopamine
inside the narrow tunnel of that one
experience and
and in that sense it's very much like
true addiction um
drugs like cocaine amphetamine in
particular but other drugs as well
for some people alcohol but not
everybody
they create a dopamine loop whereby the
drug is the only thing that can really
give that intense dopamine release and
so the way i define addiction as opposed
to a healthy focused pursuit is
addiction is a progressive narrowing of
the things that bring you pleasure right
whereas being a healthy person means you
have
three four fifty a thousand things that
bring you pleasure so you're able to
take this very basic system and use it
for different things so um
all that said you know this narrowing of
aperture is fundamental to how we
arrived to be the dominant species on
the planet right we're in charge not the
house cats because somebody took the
time and really got excited about
building tools
um that house cats if they had the idea
in mind they actually never made it
happen uh so
it's you know these systems of focus
and expanding focus and shifting focus
and then the reward system which is
universally dopamine a few other
molecules also but mostly dopamine
that's been used over and over and over
again not just for 100 years or a
thousand years but probably for hundreds
of thousands if not millions of years
so is
dopamine the only driving force in
why we seek to accomplish something
um great question uh i would say it is
the primary driving force it's it's
supported by other
molecules so
we can
very clearly state
uh from a place of i think great
confidence that dopamine is
the molecule that is creating motivation
craving and drive for things that are
outside our immediate possession or
experience beyond the confines of our
skin so seeking new relationships
seeking a new uh item that you want to
buy seeking a degree seeking a win
seeking a trophy okay seeking but
there's another set of rewards that have
to do with the feelings of pleasure that
we derive from things that we already
have
um that we experience this very
intensely around um close relationships
with people or animals that we feel
kinship with and with great great
joy from their their mere presence right
you don't need to seek them they're just
there just feels good um the meal that
you're currently preparing and eating is
very different than the food you're
trying to hunt or go by to to to eat um
and the second reward system
is mainly governed by the molecule
serotonin it's more of a
of a calm sense of reward and i we can
say that because dopamine
the molecule dopamine is actually
biochemically converted into adrenaline
it actually is the thing from which
adrenaline is created and adrenaline is
what gives us energy to move not caloric
energy but neural energy to go pursue
things
serotonin is much more woven into the
systems of the brain and body that make
us feel not just willing but perfectly
content
to stay still
like ah it's really nice here i really
love this you know the feeling of this
person is enough serotonin
well and i think the two systems compete
um and there's a and people are are you
know
skewed one way or the other somewhat um
there are skills and things that one can
do to learn to access these different
systems um
and there are other reward systems and
motivational systems too
the so-called endogenous opioid system
we all can make these endogenous kind of
painkiller feel good molecules these are
not the opioids of the opioid crisis
although the molecules are exactly the
same the opioid crisis is due to
companies making a synthetic version
of this soothing painkiller molecule and
then putting it in a pill that provides
it at very high dosages now that has
clinical uses like if you go in for a
surgery nowadays they'll prescribe
fentanyl almost
always but of course they can be abused
and they have they're highly addictive
because normally we don't experience
fentanyl levels of opioid circulating in
our body unless we've you know run a 100
mile race and we're trying to save our
family from famine or something perhaps
just as an adaptive mechanism but yeah i
would say that dopamine
is responsible for most of what humans
have accomplished and
and those who are able to access it i
have to
you know presume that this is um
probably
what your experience has been i mean
that ability to set a goal a milestone
and work toward it oh man only driving
force literally that's when people ask
me why i what i love about racing i was
like setting a goal and achieving it
yeah well and dopamine is interesting
because
it obeys a very
simple set of rules which fall under the
umbrella what's called reward prediction
error and when you hear this it's sort
of a duh but we know this from literally
recordings from neurons using electrodes
or imaging
if you suddenly get
a surprise that you like dopamine is
massively released it gets you all
excited and motivated to pursue of what
you think preceded that okay finding i
don't know for a kid walking along the
street i don't know when i was a kid i
mean 100 bill would have been like whoa
like check this out there's a lot of
money um
if you are pursuing something or someone
or any kind of milestone and you don't
reach it
there what happens is dopamine actually
increases in anticipation of potential
rewards not from the reward itself a lot
of people don't realize this and if you
don't get that let's say you are
hell-bent on a gold medal not silver not
bronze
but platform gold medal and you end up
with a silver
your baseline of dopamine drops below
what it was prior to the pursuit
athletes know this right dude i've lived
this my whole i mean
am i screwed
no
you know cognitive the beautiful thing
about the dopamine system
is that the prefrontal cortex which is
involved in planning and decision making
and rationalization is also wired into
the system so one can say okay that was
a learning experience and i the rewards
came from
the fact that i didn't get bronze or
whatever we can reframe but
in the strictest sense that's the way
dopamine reward prediction error works
now the other thing is also true which
is that
if we are in pursuit of something
and then we achieve it
there's a positive feedback loop
whereby the brain
and nervous system
better remembers all the steps that led
to that successful completion of the
milestone
so this is wired into the soul excuse me
into so-called neuroplasticity which is
our ability to change and so you start
thinking about how success breeds
success
yeah that's all about dopamine
wow you start thinking about how failure
make you know people start creating this
narrative especially in depressive
states of like
it's just not worth trying anymore in
some ways they're protecting their
subconsciously protecting the dopamine
they still have
and
and i was fascinated to learn that
recently there have been studies showing
that
people who have chronic pain
the pain itself actually starts becoming
wired into this dopamine system it's
very interesting you know they're these
people who um are always talking about
their pain sure always talking about
it's almost like gosh like for somebody
who's not in chronic pain that can be
very perplexing and sometimes even
annoying like gosh this person like all
i hear about is the hard relationship
the heart the pain
yeah and oops i don't know if that's on
my side or not
okay um but in any case
that system can start becoming its own
reward
mechanism whereby the thinking about the
pain actually starts to trigger dopamine
release and so this is a a rather this
is a adaptive
circuit so there's a lot of dimensions
that this could go but
for somebody who's very driven who wants
to be the best who has a milestone i
would say two cautionary notes one first
first of all that's beautiful and that's
wonderful and that's a lot of what makes
life rich two
one needs to make sure that along the
way
you are registering the wins the the
milestones settings closer horizon
milestones yeah yep and then the third
is that
the schedule of reward that works best
for keeping people in a healthy state of
mind of pursuit
is one of the same one that the casinos
use
to extract money from you which is
random intermittent reward here's what i
mean the slot machine it does it's not
every 10 pulls that keeps people playing
a win every 10 pulls it's the randomness
of it right as soon as you're ready to
walk away you get a win and then it
keeps people going
this we can apply this in our own lives
that in this especially true with kids
it's great to reward your wins
but every once in a while
take that gold medal
and just say don't say it wasn't good
enough but just
go right back into living life and
pursuing new
new pursuits what what i've seen over
and over again is that people that are
very driven
become so attached to this dopamine
reward system that they get the rew
they reach the milestone excuse me and
then
they feel depressed well why because
dopamine is released by pursuit
motivation and craving not by
reaching the reward itself so the
journey being the destination is a is a
dope again a dopaminergic as we say
phenomenon ah so it's important to have
goals perhaps very lofty goals the
long-term ones so that you stay in the
pursuit for longer but then like you
said you need the incremental goals to
stay satisfied essentially and correct
and and to keep you
driven
so dopamine
there's a beautiful experiment that
illustrates this has been done in
animals and and just by way of natural
circumstances in humans let's talk about
the animal experiment because it's
simple you take two rats separate cages
um rats like food and they'll ever press
for
a piece of chocolate or something tasty
especially um they can achieve pleasure
now you take those rats and you put them
behind a little wall
or they have to do some work like climb
over the wall to get the lever both of
them will do that now you take one of
those rats
and again this was done with humans as
well and you deplete its dopamine
you put them in right in front of the
lever both of them will sit there and
eat the food dope dopamine is not
required to experience pleasure but now
if you remove the wall but you put the
rats just one rat length away from the
lever what you'll notice is the one that
has dopamine because it's a normal rat
will walk towards the lever press it and
get the food
the rat or person who does not have
dopamine won't even move one body length
away to reach pleasure
so the key takeaway here
whether or not you're a highly driven
person or not is that
rewards achieved
without prior effort
don't tap into the dopamine system
and
they basically will [ __ ] an organism
or human
at the level of the mind
such that you can't
really experience pleasure the same way
what do i mean by this so if you're
scrolling on instagram for an hour a day
and that's great
it feels great you see things you see
people you get some likes you put some
comments you know etc
if you do that over and over what you
find is that you're sort of on there but
you don't even know why or if you've
ever eaten a delicious pizza when you're
hungry
tastes great but if you've ever just
sort of been eating you don't even know
why you're eating it doesn't even taste
that good and yet you feel this
compulsion to keep going and that's
because
the whole dopamine system is really
geared towards trying to re-establish
this baseline and that if we know one
thing
for sure about dopamine is that if you
have a big peak of dopamine
it always goes back down to baseline and
sometimes a little bit below baseline
and that below baseline generates a
feeling of pain and lack this is well
known neurochemically it's well known
psychologically after a big win there's
always going to be a crash sometimes
next day sometimes three weeks later
that crash
is actually
a
resetting mechanism of levels of
dopamine so if you're ever feeling
especially low and like you're not
motivated
it could be one of two things one you're
not in pursuit enough but if that low or
a motivation comes from or lack of
motivation comes from
having been working really hard or in
pursuit
you need some rest in order to reset the
dopamine system a lot of people that
experience a big win or there's this
phenomenon of postpartum depression
um you know a child finally arrives it's
born and then some and
then oftentimes men too but more often
this is described for women will feel
intense depression um the anticipation
is gone
and this can be very detrimental of
course for them and for the baby but
it's there's a all that needs to happen
is a waiting period where we are not in
pursuit
and then it comes back to baseline so
everyone differs in terms of how long
and how you know how much to pursue
things but once we learn to kind of
dance with these mechanisms we can learn
to really be in pursuit and then
throttle back i'm sure it's a lot like
driving i don't know anything about race
car driving but i get the sense from
watching a few races that it seems like
they're not
racing the whole time is that right is
that yeah there are definitely times
where you're more conservative or you're
playing it safe or you're conserving
your tires or fuel or
you know something like that there are
times like that for sure
and i guess you have the pit stop in
racing which um
is sort of yeah i guess it's sort of
analogous to some of these neurochemical
resets yeah
yeah
in any event i guess we went down the
rabbit hole of dopamine right right but
that is i think
at our core
i think dopamine is responsible for so
much of our our life experience yeah so
will we always get back to baseline if
we rest enough or
are there ways to lower your
baseline dopamine levels and if there is
how do you get them back up again yeah
so the quickest way to deplete your
dopamine and to end up in a in a vicious
often dangerous cycle of um pursuit is
any of the classic uh descrip
addictive drugs so especially the drugs
that trigger dopamine release so um
cocaine and amphetamine are the most
famous
for creating the most dopamine release
and as a consequence what happens is
okay so let's say
and i of course i'll just say it i mean
no one should use these drugs these are
very destructive for the following
reason the first time somebody uses
cocaine or amphetamine they get a
massive increase in dopamine
because of the way those drugs are
chemically structured then the next time
it's a little bit less and a little bit
less and a little bit less and they use
the same amount or progressively more
and more and they're now dropping below
baseline just to get to normal
right any addict knows this
um
now behaviors can do the same thing for
some people these are called process
addictions but shopping addictions sex
addiction porn addiction uh
adrenaline addiction i mean people have
their ever you know different people
have their things some people have less
of an addictive personality some people
more
uh there's some genetic biases there in
terms of the there's certainly
circumstantial biases right if we know
one thing for sure if if someone never
has access to a drug they're less likely
to abuse that drug um
this is i'm not trying to get out of my
mind yeah oh that's that's well
established i mean uh to i'm not getting
into the legal or political side of this
but um
there are other dangers with making
certain things illegal too so you know
that's a that's a political legal
discussion but in terms of the biology
um
the key here is to understand that
the bigger the dopamine increase the
bigger the crash
and the less likely it is that you'll
ever continue to achieve pleasure from
that thing so let's take it to a maybe a
less sinister set of examples let's say
the kind of person that likes exercise
but now you decide yeah i love exercise
but now you decide you're going to
listen to music while you exercise which
itself kind of boosts your dopamine
great that's great but now that peak is
getting a little bit bigger now let's
say
you're like me and you like a double
espresso before
doing any exercise great and then now
let's say you add to that one of the
more high potency um pre-workout drinks
that are out there with say l-tyrosine
which is the amino acid precursor to
dopamine great i've taken those there's
some terrific ones out there you you
feel like you can conquer the world plus
music but okay great now let's say
um you do that a few times
and you notice you need a bit more of
the pre-workout drink the music to be a
little bit louder and
it doesn't quite feel like the first
time
right what's happening is you're
starting to do what's called dopamine
layering or stacking you're starting to
bring in more and more things
um
people
will take there are natural behaviors
that for evolutionary reasons make
perfect sense um human reproduction is
closely tethered to the to the dopamine
system and i'm not just talking about
sex the verb i'm talking also about the
pursuit of a mate the excitement about
somebody new you know that the feeling
that you don't need to sleep and life is
so amazing in the early part of a
romantic love it that's dopamine that's
just pure dopamine like the the thinking
about them all day that's that shrinking
of the narrow of the visual aperture and
the sort of cognitive aperture also
right and then typically that will be uh
you know because
evolution also understands that we need
to like nourish ourselves and get sleep
and live our lives and things right i
mean although we've probably you and i
probably both know people that they fall
in love and they sort of stop doing
anything else besides fixating on the
person right i just general message to
the people out there like that's not
conducive to the success of the
relationship you know
missing someone is actually a case of
dopamine reward prediction error
texting someone and not hearing back is
reward prediction error in the negatives
right here it is they always respond on
a certain latency it's like the slot
machine every 10th pull now it's like
what happened that's that anticipation
like hey hey what's going on that's
dopamine again um
so in a typical scenario though we can
leverage this stuff by just
understanding that there's nothing wrong
with dopamine peaks
there's nothing wrong with being really
excited and happy and motivated that's
beautiful um but we need to toggle back
and forth between dopamine states
and rest states and i think that a lot
of people who are very driven or excited
about the next thing the new thing you
know you saw this the other day right
kids get ice cream you give them ice
cream and they take the first lick of
ice cream and they want to know can we
have ice cream tomorrow also
but they're completely out of the
experience of it and you're not trying
to create littles like zen buddhists
where you're like oh wait let's be in
the experience of the ice cream but it's
so interesting to see that the way the
mind works because and and here there's
a great book about dopamine they're two
actually neither of which i had anything
to do with unfortunately i would have
loved to write these but the first one
is called the molecule of more because
dopamine is all about
more
if you find yourself eating a piece of
chocolate and your first sense is oh
that's delicious i'm savoring it
i want more
that's the dopamine system putting you
into anticipation of the next
little blip of dopamine um there's the
book the molecule more speaks to this in
a number of different ways it's a
beautiful book
the other book that talks more about
sort of the pitfalls of dopamine and how
it can lead to addiction
both substance abuse and behavioral
addictions is the book by my colleague
at stanford dr anna lemke who runs our
dual diagnosis
addiction clinic she's a md and
psychiatrist and it's called dopamine
nation
and it's about
dopamine and how it can take us down
these somewhat complicated paths she
actually talks about her own
uh behavioral addiction that she
developed
explains that and the solution to this
is generally 30 days at least of no
interaction with whatever the thing is
which for some people might seem
excruciating but um that's generally the
reset
um but the stereotype it's now chocolate
how do i do how do i do that well i'll
tell you one thing it will make
chocolate taste that much better when
you return to it oh i'm sure
um it will make it feel like the first
time right
and yet you know we of course don't have
to be neuroscience uh stoics about all
this you know life is to be enjoyed so
but i think if one is getting less
pleasure from the same things
oftentimes it means not pursuing that
thing or other kind of high dopamine
states quite as much yeah good evidence
for that this is why um
you know
nowadays there's talk about dopamine
detox which is this kind of extreme
version of like not experiencing any
pleasure i think that's a little bit
much
there are also some interesting things
that many people like myself enjoy
caffeine caffeine increases dopamine
receptors which make whatever dopamine
is available
more effective in driving dopamine
increases so i would say toggle it right
yeah
and
and i guess with you know i should ask
you in you know in your
race car driving career
um
were there times in which you felt
that
the pursuit just wasn't giving you the
same edge and in which case did you
think about bigger goals or did you
think about kind of bringing the horizon
in towards smaller goals yeah that
definitely happens where you can kind of
i think that's actually i feel like that
almost happens kind of more macro levels
for your career when you kind of just
lose the spark for it
it kind of comes and goes i think
on a micro level race to race weekend
but i think about it more prevalently in
the macro of your career where you just
kind of lose the drive for it anymore
it's just something's not really
motivating you anymore it's not fun it's
not
you know you start thinking about the
negatives you're thinking about the
danger or thinking about the things that
you've sow
tunnel vision
ignored and not seen
but that yeah i think that's what
happens and i think that uh especially
in sports i think usually when it that
probably does happen that's i think why
careers end quickly is because you're at
such at a level and there's such an
amount of energy and effort and danger
in some some cases that you you're just
you can't put yourself in that scenario
anymore
even if you're just slightly out
yeah danger is an interesting one
because um
danger and the relief that comes from
escaping danger can have their own
um kind of addictive loop i was watching
this on a
movie of course a free solo right oh
yeah yeah yeah like alex honold i mean i
apparently he and these are his words
not mine neurologically he seems skewed
towards experiencing less anxiety and
fear
than
than typical people would he he may have
some wiring either by experience or by
genetics or both that
kind of lead him to be less stressed in
high-risk high consequent circumstances
but you know that's an interesting movie
because
you know he lives
and yet yeah still freaks you out to
watch and i don't think it's just the
visuals so it's the possibility that he
might fall that is essentially the crux
of the movie although they did a good
job of making about him also and his i
would say his more um
i don't know like his philanthropy and
some of his other efforts too absolutely
i think that the
i think the key thing here is to have
again addiction is an error progressive
narrowing of the things that bring us
pleasure and i don't know anything about
enlightenment but i would say that a
good life is one in which you can derive
pleasure from
your morning cup of coffee the sunshine
interactions with people and your big
bigger goals
we so reward especially in the u.s right
we so reward
people who just
you know set that like michael jordan
level of focus i mean that because they
they provide the entertainment
for the rest of us
right
i'm not a big basketball fan but if
we're going to watch basketball i'd
probably you know enjoy watching him
because he what he does is so phenomenal
or we did right but you know the cost
to that person's nervous system
and to the nervous systems of the people
around them is is a real one
um i don't get away with anything
yeah exactly and and to test
you know because
there
those people often end up in a
circumstance where
they can't have much pleasure unless
they're winning and it was interesting
in that last dance documentary about
jordan where he talks about how even if
he was just playing a game for adopt for
a dollar
it was like
clearly competition was his dopamine
yeah yeah and and that's beautiful too
right we need people like that yeah
so i think that
he i found it he was fascinating that i
found that he
um seemed like he almost artificially
sort of built up
rivalries and like frustrations and
um
uh
like a battle in his head like oh you
think that about me and it might not
have even been that true he but it just
seemed like he exacerbated these ideas
and it became his driving force
um it was kind of a fascinating
psychological
you know uh
show
it was and and you know as somebody you
know i've always loved biology and
science and but you know i made a
decision my freshman year uh at the end
of my freshman year of college it was
you know phd by time i'm 30
junior faculty member professor by time
i'm 35 10-year stanford at harvard by
time i'm four years like that was it
like focus like that was it and i had
some other goals too i want to you know
maintain decent physical shape and be a
nice person and like other things too
but when i finally reached those goals i
actually had a big crash i was like what
do i do now i didn't have a next phase
goal i knew i wanted to continue doing
science and eventually public
communication of science but it's so
important that we have goals
because again goals and milestones are
the thing of motivation and excitement
we just can't have only those goals we
need many goals we have to have the goal
of you know making a great omelette for
breakfast which i still haven't mastered
right
we have to have all these goals of uh
for ourselves all day long i forget who
said it was it like saint augustine or
something said that like a good life
requires a like a constant reordering of
our loves or something like that i'm
terrible at quotes but constantly
updating
what it is that we
that we are in love with for that moment
and then shifting to the next thing and
of course that serotonin system is vital
you know if
if we cannot enjoy the things that we
already have and that require no pursuit
if we can't take ourselves into those
moments of just really appreciating what
we have and and not just gratitude but
really
savoring the experience of what we're in
we will never be able to go back to the
goal pursuit mode
as of as well or as efficiently so it
really is like the see-sawing back and
forth between
loving a good night's sleep
but also loving being the person who
bounces out of bed in the morning with a
goal right um
loving
like being for me you know like just
being a total sloth all day one day a
week i mean i turn into it like i
literally think about the animal the
sloth i even have a sloth on it that day
it's ridiculous
just i literally take a full day of each
week and try and just
enjoy being in
the microscope of like
just hanging around and doing that i
don't always achieve that because of
life constraints but
then also on monday morning or sunday if
it were whatever your schedule is
really putting you know the goal in the
crosshairs and getting that dopamine
system ramped up again oh man that's
that's a good goal i i'm not sure i
could achieve the one day of doing
nothing but i think that's actually a
good goal it always seems like it's
about cycling with everything i'm
curious how this plays into
relationships because i'm quite quite
fascinated with relationships and
the point of them and the balance and
the
real nature human nature of them
and i'm wondering if relationship
because it's something we seek and then
it's something we accomplish
essentially at some points in time
sometimes once sometimes many times um
and then
you know sometimes they end but also
once you get them there's some sort of
an end to the seeking and so i'm curious
about how this dopamine loop plays into
relationships
yeah relationships are
fascinating i think are at least within
the quadrant of key things for our
evolution right because up until now
we've been talking about dopamine and
serotonin in this kind of fixed unimodal
way like one person and the goal
and maybe in race car driving where it
broadens the context too well there are
other people chasing a goal and there
can only be one winner right but in
relationships everything changes because
now you're talking about
two nervous systems right or if you
think about a family
you know is more than two you're saying
about
multiple systems each with their own set
of motivational
constraints interacting and controlling
each other's dopamine so it becomes a
very hard problem at that at the
experimental level in the lab on the
other hand there are a number of things
known about this and we did an episode
of my podcast on on
your attachment and um oh yeah i listen
to the whole thing
okay um
i always joke the episodes in my podcast
are very long and um
but i did
well the um i was joking if nothing else
i'll cure insomnia but the um but but in
terms of relationships there are a
couple of core things um that we we can
that we know for sure first of all
parent or we should say caretaker child
attachment during development sets the
template right
two that template can be modified
three
we should underscore the first one which
is that the neural circuitry that
defines healthy secure attachment or
insecure attachment or anxious
attachment or avoidant attachment all
these things we could get into in detail
if you like okay
those are repurposed
in romantic relationships the brain does
not take real estate that it formed in
development and just say oh that was for
childhood now i'm an adult it repurposes
it so
but there's another rule which is very
important and is often overlooked and i
just really want to illustrate this
these
relationships that are established in
childhood
are repurposed and romantic and other
types of relationships in adulthood but
that doesn't mean that it's one for one
in terms of of like dad mom let me
explain let's say um
there's a a young woman or a baby right
who grows up a young child and she has a
great relationship with her dad
loving secure he's he's honest
predictable reliable um they have good
rapport it's a strong feelings of
support but let's say she has a um
negative relationship with her mother
it's anxious avoidant there's condemning
there's um it's it feels insecure that's
unpredictable all the kinds of things we
associate with with attachment
let's say in this particular example
this young girl
defines herself as and is heterosexual
she's attracted to males okay
when she grows up she may find herself
may find herself getting in
relationships with people that are not
secure and
and
you know and behaving like her dad you
may she may find that she's drawn to
um men that are that are like mildly
abusive or avoidant or
and you say well how could that be she
had a great relationship with her dad
it always always always there is a this
rule in psychoanalysis and in psychology
which is that none of this stuff
is wired for one specific gender or the
other her preference is she in this
example hypothetical example she's
heterosexual she's only attracted to to
men romantically but the attachment
circuitry
what feeds the reward system and
predictability and punishment systems
etc
can be very much
superimposed from the relationship with
mom which was not good in this example
to the dad and this is really key
because people
someone had a great relationship with to
their dad great dad why would she end up
with these with these you know
these terrible men and maybe all men are
bad or whatever and
um that's not the way it works the
circuitry
is it runs an algorithm it's like two
plus
two plus two equals five in this person
and you got like two plus two doesn't
equal five she knows it doesn't like
this is crazy but i'm not
in her mind she's thinking oh you know
i'm not drawn to people that are healthy
for me why would that be okay so that's
an important thing to illustrate because
i think a lot of times we hear childhood
attachment translates to adults
attachment and people overlook the fact
that there can be a swapping
of
gender in these kind of arrangements
okay
and there needs to be a relearning
unfortunately the relearning can occur
there's a great book called attached
that helps people this is written by two
psychologists that helps people define
their attachment style and um i don't
know that they made this point about
crossover uh from mother or father to
adult preference as salient as maybe
they should have but in any case now in
terms of relationship let's think of the
typical arc of relationship two people
meet
we're thinking romantic relationship now
um
they mean there's a there's an interest
there's there's either
you one would hope a physical attraction
end in intellectual emotional attachment
or attraction
so there's a number of like potential
rewards there and then
you know the dance that is relationship
making is one of
people entering up off um
vacation or entering living together or
um you know even just the whole dance of
who pays for things it's like people are
offering resources and people are
getting excited in anticipation they're
they're failures right so and so didn't
call back they canceled they're they're
consistent like the things of value
that one values become the things of
dopamine reward prediction error okay if
you value communication consistency
and um
throughput
for someone to to provide those would
give you immense dopamine release like
wow this person is really reliable now
here's the thinger for certain people
that is important to them but they just
sort of expect it right so if someone
does it it's not like they're like wow
this person is so great this is the
danger of having a healthy upbringing i
always joke is that like of course like
it's like someone who grows up with uh
two ferraris in the in the parking lot
um out in the driveway and then someone
picks them up in a really nice car and
they're like yeah like ferraris are kind
of the way life works right that wasn't
yeah your bmw is fine but
exactly so there's always this kind of
unique tailoring of how the dopamine
system works but what we know for sure
is that the early phases of relationship
is just a negotiating of rewards and
let's hope not punishment now at some
point if people enter a committed
relationship
there is this attenuation of novelty and
novelty is
is this remember the surprise the the
novelty is the strongest stimulus for
dopamine when one doesn't expect
something to happen and it happens and
it's positive the dopamine system goes
crazy
just like and and over time as we learn
to predict people's behavior you know
like someone brings flowers every friday
that's beautiful but
if they don't bring it on a friday oh
yeah
if they do it every friday remember i'm
not saying you people shouldn't do that
i love these routines that people build
but if they but if they bring it every
friday it does not have the same potency
i have a question before you we we kind
of evolved this arc of relationships and
what it means so you talked about
that
things that we value like the
relationship gets established on things
that we value
and i'm wondering if within the
circuitry from childhood
that
while it's not healthy there is a
hormonal value
for your own loop of whatever it is that
you seek for the dopamine hit and it
doesn't need to be good is that
something that you value and that is
that why you get into unhealthy
relationships
example being
you know you um
you know your mother was in this
scenario you gave the dad is sort of
secure and reliable but the mom is um
maybe more of the problem and so you
seek the loop of your mother you're
seeking that loop and there's a dopamine
hit with it so is that part of the
problem with relationships that exists
if we don't understand what our
unhealthy dopamine hits are that we tend
to find ourselves in unhealthy
relationships
uh the short answer is yes and um
there is a name for it in the psychology
literature it's the so-called repetition
compulsion like why would somebody
continue to put themselves into
scenarios that are emotionally or even
physically dangerous for them
that the older psychoanal analytic view
of this and it may be right was that
one does that someone does that
subconsciously as a way to try and get
it right again and again
and correct the original wound right
wreck the original wound some people of
course will take their childhood and say
i'm never ever ever going to be with a
person like that and they and this is
always beautiful when one sees it right
it's like they have a friend she grew up
in a home and it was it just financially
was a very complicated place and so she
prioritized being in a stable financial
situation it wasn't about being wealthy
it was just stability and never deviated
from that
but other people might engage in the
repetition compulsion of being in these
kind of tumultuous financial situations
and it's the resolution and failure and
resolution failure that seems to be the
drug for them the short answer is yes i
mean i think that these reward
mechanisms are set very early on
fortunately they can be modified again
we have this power of awareness that
this is why talking about
these reward mechanisms and
understanding them actually has
applied value
there's not like a drug that you can
take to suddenly change these these
reward mechanisms understanding how they
work i do believe and there's evidence
for the fact that
they really can help us reshape what's
important is we can say gosh it's like a
car that wants it here i'm using all
these automobile things
i love it it's fine it's like when
you're out of when it's out of alignment
like it's veering right it's like
veering right so you just know you kind
of have to turn the wheel a little bit
more you have to kind of like like lean
into 11 o'clock or else it's gonna just
veer you just know that and the
challenge is it takes effort just you
know and it takes attention but when our
default state is to take us
to uh unhealthy places you know uh
there's a friend of mine who's a superb
psychiatrist um and he always uh um you
know
he always says about relationships you
know you get this person who um
has been in
they'll say i've been in seven
abusive relationships and he says no
actually you've been in one
relationship seven times it's it's the
same thing right it's not just a word
yeah it's not just a word word flip um
and forgive me i misspoke this isn't a
friend i i have a friend who's a
psychiatrist this isn't a friend of mine
um this is a former guest on the podcast
paul conte doctor oh yeah yep i've
talked to him he's done amazing work on
trauma i think that was where paul's
words and specifically and i i
we're friendly but but i want to be
clear about the the original source of
that so
i think the key here is that when one
starts to understand like gosh i'm
really drawn to this thing
that when you understand that one can
start making
taking steps to to move away from it now
the problem with this all dopamine thing
in the context of relationship is that
early on
it's incredibly intoxicating to the
point where oftentimes people don't
realize that they're veering
so hard right that that you know and and
this is where the the power of friends
um comes in very handy this is also
where
we can honestly say that the power of
complete and total disclosure about
relationship to friend or therapist is
really healthy if you're saying like you
know i've seen this with some of my male
friends
i have female friends too but most of my
friends just happen to email at this
stage of life that's just kind of my
surroundings and i get the friend that's
super excited about somebody and they'll
tell you this story about this say oh
you know and there was this crazy thing
she did this crazy thing and they get
kind of wide-eyed and like that doesn't
sound good he's like excited about it
like okay this is this is your this is
his drug right it's uncertainty it's
excitement and i and it follows a very
predictable pattern where in three to
six months it's
him complaining that she's crazy or that
the relationship is a mess or that the
original thing you love now you hate
exactly there's chaos so i think that
here's the i think the takeaway for
relationships not just at the beginning
not just in the middle
um we talk about the end in a minute if
there is one but
to have an awareness where if you sense
too much excitement in yourself
or too much anticipation of how great
someone is
i'm not saying don't fall in love but be
very cautious about the extremes of
dopamine be very wary about the thing
that makes you feel incredible
and i i say this with some trepidation
because i myself you know love love
right i love love i love love but love
following you know the best love falling
in love love being in love i mean that's
true in romantic relationships and i
also you know i i love having a bulldog
like i love tim you know love love love
you know i have so many loves in life
and relationships that are always the
best of it right but there is this
element where
it is a bit of a
drug right it's this thing because it's
always about more and if you really want
the relationship if you want good
clarity on the relationship and you want
it to last there has to be a tempering
of that and i don't mean um playing
aloof i don't mean canceling things last
minute i don't mean playing any kind of
games with the dopamine reward
prediction error thing what i mean is
just being aware that that chemical
state
it it really is a what comes up comes
goes down and it also puts tremendous
demand on the other person
right
that i think the key of any good
relationship is to be able to toggle
back and forth ideally in para like
together through these more dopaminergic
like novelty excitement
and then the more like really getting
joy out of just being together the more
serotonergic stuff like that just like
wow the sweetness the incredible like
the cocoon
and missing one another is super healthy
also remember
addiction is a progressive narrowing of
the things that bring us pleasure making
sure that we continue to derive
excitement from other things in life
even when we're falling in love you know
the concept of the muse and the concept
of in a new relationship we feel kind of
indestructible we can do anything in
life and feeling so inspired you know
you see this people you joyful excited
oh i've seen this in family members also
like working out again and you're like
wow they're using it but the problem is
it's all anchored it's all tethered to
this relationship and the relationship
goes and then the rest of stuff goes too
so
again being able to access these
motivational reward systems in a bunch
of contacts so critical and then of
course
we see the opposite too i have a lot of
friends who've been married for a long
time and they're like yeah like we never
do anything anymore
they're only in that kind of search
energy you're going to say we never do
it anymore or yeah so we won't do it
anymore and sex is a huge i mean it's
we know one thing for sure which is that
all of us are here because either in a
dish or in a well eventually in a body
sperm egg and develop that's just the
reality and that whole process that we
call sex sexual reproduction
is strongly anchored to what's called
the autonomic arousal system whereby
there's excitement and then but it can't
be too much excitement it's got to be
calm because if it's too much excitement
it actually inhibits the sexual response
that um believe it or not the orgasm
response in both men and women is driven
by the stress system of the body but it
has this positive valence we say it's a
lot of dopamine and then the why because
then afterwards
whatever that happens to be
there's a
return to below baseline levels of
energy this is we think that the just so
story about this is that it's likely so
that people will exchange
smells to pair bond
right because pair bonding is pretty
vital to human
partnership um and
obviously people can have sex not just
to raise to produce and raise young but
then so the whole like seesawing back
and forth and then it repeats right at
whatever frequency that couple is for
them but that whole process is one in
which dopamine is strongly released in
anticipation and during sex and and then
afterwards it plummets and there's
another molecule called prolactin which
skyrockets
prolactin actually sets the refractory
period
in which at least for males sex can't
happen again
and
what are the other things that induce
prolactin in males and females well
child rearing
la it's linked to the lactation
process oh wow the the the like the the
coziness thing is not dopaminergic it's
prolactin it's it's basically driven by
prolactin oxytocin and serotonin so this
seesawing back and forth is is at the
core of who we are it's at the core of
how we got here all our parents one way
or another went through this process
you know i was trying to think of the
exceptions i'm always teased that i
think of every qualify i suppose in in
vitro fertilization the
mother and the father went through this
process in separate
areas of the world but nonetheless each
one went through the process in more
standard natural
reproduction as we call it they
took place presumably in the same
place
so
this is how we got here this is how we
work and i think learning to toggle back
and forth between excitement and
anticipation but never hitting that
absolute extreme excitement is a very
useful thing don't ever hit the ceiling
ever in that way you maintain motivation
you maintain excitement and learn how to
toggle back and forth
so is it possible because i'm just
thinking about myself at times in my
life or somebody out there listening
is it possible to both be so excited and
connected that you feel that huge drive
and push to like mate and be together
and spend time
or is that um overly heightened
dopamine or
state
uh an indication of uh
an unhealthy
loop or pattern relationship
into people
well i think it can be healthy i mean i
think and also remember dopamine is a
generic molecule so for instance this is
if ever there was a a justification for
maintaining a lot of different interests
and things that can generate dopamine
here's one when you're we talked about
before when you're in a relationship
that's really great you feel more energy
to do other things the substrate by
which adrenaline is created etc
um
well the other the opposite is also true
you know you imagine the couple and one
is doing kind of well in life they're
excited about life the other one is not
well the person who's excited about life
is sort of like is in a position to be
more excited about the relationship you
know if you come home from a great day
at work
um or you've got a lot going on you
bring that to the relationship that
dopamine bleeds over it's like because
dopamine is all about possibility it's
like hey let's take a vacation this year
let's or let's take it it could be
simple thing like let's just take a walk
or let's start like going for a swim in
the morning or like it's all about like
let's create newness right so there is a
way in which you could one can leverage
different components of life in order to
be more excited about the relationship
they're in i think that
there's another piece to this which is
you know
which is i think what you're asking
correct me if i'm wrong which is that
you know if it if we're too excited
about the relationship will it
inevitably fail and i think the answer
is no one of the amazing things about
love and relationships is that it's
really about creating a story in one's
mind about the past and what it means
and projecting that story forward and
and that's that's something that is just
incredible right as that's sure mating
isn't sex is involved but it's not just
about that i always joke you know sex is
necessary but not sufficient right you
need the other elements of and and one
of the amazing things about this thing
of love and attachment is that it's not
all just chemicals and neurotransmitters
i don't want to give that impression
it's also about this ability to to write
to mutually write a story
like we met there was this this spark
there was this thing there was this
mutual interest we made it through this
hard thing we you know and the key thing
remember dopamine is about projecting
into the future it is important
to not just have plans but to sort of
take that story and project it into
an infinite number of sequels
not just the one blockbuster picture
that came out and ended and now we're
just going to kind of sit together and
only focus on kids although kids are a
whole other separate beautiful dimension
of this
some people don't want them and
oftentimes people will have them
thinking that it's going to create it's
going to bring novelty to the
relationship i know so many people who
have gotten divorced about seven or
after their kids are about seven to nine
years old i'm like what is going on here
i think that there are a number of
different sort of transitions at that
stage where the kids are no longer
providing a ton of novelty they need
slightly less caretaking although still
substantial amounts of caretaking so i
think that once
one understands how these mechanisms
work you can start to layer them in in
ways that meet people's different life
requirements the other thing is the
breakup part just mentioned this that in
an episode on grieving and breaking of
attachments
the brain has a three-part map of all
attachments whether or not it's to a
person or to an animal romantic or
non-romantic we want to know where they
are in space like literally are they in
paris right now are they here where are
they yeah where they are in time like
are they present now when will i see
them again
and then there's this attachment map and
those three things are tethered think of
it like a tripod they're tethered when
somebody
when we break up or somebody dies
or if we anticipate that a relationship
is going to end
it the grieving process we know based on
neuroimaging taps into the reward system
and creates a system where we are
anticipating the the reward of love and
attachment and connection but it's never
going to come and that is it it's like
an over activation of
desire desire
when but with the knowledge that there's
nothing right there if someone passes
away we're sometimes familiar with like
turning around expecting to see them the
brain expects to see them because the
brain has seen them every time we've
turned around
you know waking up with the bed empty
next to us is incredibly like it's i
mean we hopefully people experience at
least one breakup in their life i think
it's actually a healthy thing to
experience that maybe get back together
don't do it don't break up just to do
this folks but um but that feeling of
like god like it's like this yearning
well that's the hungry
animal or human who's the food is just
out of reach
and the grieving process is one of
reordering that map to understand okay
maybe this person is not in their
current physical form their die they've
died maybe that person isn't available
to us because they there's a breakup
yeah understand that the craving is
setting up literally a pain in the body
remember pain and pleasure are toggling
also it's
physical and mental anguish
because
it's right outside our reach and even
though we cognitively understand
that
it's not available to us the body still
wants it and so it takes you know i
think the current estimates based on
imaging and other studies are it's about
60 days of no contact that means no text
no scrolling and seeing their social
media no looking at pictures of them no
listing your favorite songs no selling
their shirts or other things
60 days or so to reset those mechanisms
just to get back to kind of neutral
unless it was a terrible relationship in
which case people are celebrating
what makes someone
have a more emotional breakup than
another
oh that's a great question there's a
phenomenon called
and this is beautiful work done by mary
frances o'connor at the university of
arizona um she's written a wonderful
book about this there's something called
the complex or complicated grief
complex complicated grief is grief that
goes on much longer and it has a kind of
more of a depressive like state to it
it's the person who's still talking
about the person that they
broke up with or that broke up with them
uh two years later oh my goodness it's
so annoying to friends and family and
yet that person is really in a in a
place of intense
complicated grief sorry to acknowledge
that and oftentimes if someone died then
that complicated grief can extend even
longer complicated grief is
um tends to happen more in people that
have poor anxiety and stress coping
mechanisms going into the relationship
so like the anxious attachment or avoid
an attachment or something or more of an
anxious attachment could be it could
also be that the person just naturally
um their uh sort of like idling rpm is
higher
we all have this like so for instance
some people move around a lot more just
standing around um some people are just
you know calmer uh
i always like to compare people to
animals and
bulldog
bulldogs and bulldog breeds for instance
are incredibly like most of the time
unless there's something to be excited
about if you look at a pit bull type
breed or a terrier they kind of have a
lot of belgian malinois yeah exactly you
have a malinois amazing uh my neighbors
have a malinois yeah that thing is like
up and down the fence line oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah costello my bulldog he's dead
now but he he would um
i mean costello that the the roomba
vacuum
[Music]
would hit him in the face
and
he wouldn't even blink he was just like
because that's the bulldog right the
bulldog is an incredibly what we call
parasympathetic dominant animal it's
autonomic nervous system just idles
just above sleep whereas i need some
more bulldog in me
yeah yeah i mean i got him because i
mean as you can probably tell i you know
i i like
you know i think talk and move fast and
um but you're sitting in during the
interview aren't you yeah well what's
that are you standing during the
interview today i'm standing i actually
don't do anything quickly
i don't like in life i'm i'm very slow
very i don't do anything quickly okay
like i suppose i eat kind of fast but i
just don't do anything quickly um
and
but if i'm excited by something
obviously i'll try and pack as much
information in there as i possibly can
but i got costillo because
i thought that his demeanor was just a
great demeanor to have around it's
incredibly calming
so i think that
you know we we all have a kind of a a
baseline rpm and there are tools like
breathing tools i've talked about some
of these before you can do double
inhales through the nose and long
exhales through the mouth
to rapidly de-stress the so-called
physiological side you can get massages
do saunas exercise like we're all doing
things to manage our stress level some
people are doing it to kind of burn off
the extra energy we have other people
are doing it to get energy it varies but
people who are naturally have what's uh
what we call a high pre-pulse startle so
if you walk up behind
me and you say andrew i'll lightly go
yup but some people
you say um hello and they'll go
yep
and then other people you go hello yeah
right so pre-paul startle like in one
case sort of like moderate like reaction
time and some people sort of like yeah
like hey mellow and then other people
are they're jumpy
you go hi and they go right they're
jumpy their autonomic nervous system is
kind of idling in like they're not
redlining but they're close and they're
closer to a panic attack all the time
so there's people can use to bring that
down
i think that the data pretty clearly
show that
complicated grief is often
predicted by people that have a higher
level of anxiety going in or a higher
propensity for depression so even if
you're somebody who hasn't experienced a
major loss due to breakup or death if
you consider yourself a kind of anxious
person
then
i would highly recommend accessing some
of the behavioral tools to try and learn
how to control your nervous system so
that when those losses inevitably come
yeah inevitably come
so and they're a part of life and and
being able to navigate those in a clear
coherent way is is never a perfect
process there's no there's an art to it
but no one does this well if you live a
good life and you love people
when they die it just plain hurts fair
yeah that love has no place to go
it's like like grief is love with no
place to go what if you're i mean i'm
just i'm speaking from experience like
i've gone through this but i'm not an
anxious person i've only
experienced anxiety like twice two or
three times in my life
um and it was a very isolated little
short period of time so i'm not an
anxious person but i did go through
oh what felt like a very difficult
breakup and
so is it also
is there an
aspect of
a more traumatic breakup that
is associated with
perhaps
trauma
past trauma and
interpersonal interpersonal dynamics
that are unhealthy that have yet to be
resolved
and that's the extra pain
sure i mean yes and i think you know
this can
be nuanced and complicated and it you
know obviously um
you know breakups that involve uh you
know heavy
financial negotiations child
negotiations
spit pet negotiations right like i've
been through this before it's like
[Music]
yeah or even if you don't sometimes it's
even worse if you're not fighting over
it it's because you you
both want to be together as the dog
parent but you don't want to be together
a couple right it's like like human
attachment is so complicated in this way
um i still think that they're worth
pursuing and investing in but i think
that um
look trauma is a very real part of it i
mean
just like dopamine is a generic system
serotonin is a generic system
essentially wired into us to deal with
lots of different kinds of situations
well
so too
that
the attachment system is
you know is wired for you know we'd all
love to think about the one person that
is for us but of course
they're
small in most cases but a number of
different people that we could
potentially bond with in a healthy way
and when that ends there's a whole set
of
ideas about loss being generic right
like people start feeling a loss of a
relationship and
they start feeling all it's as if they
start feeling all the other losses that
they had like the relationship before
that and people started talking about
gosh it never works out in all these
things and they kind of overlook the
fact that they've had so many
relationships and it's worked to create
but then
break up potentially over and over again
so i think that the
the key theme here is that
the
the systems of of moving apart
can can reactivate or kind of cue us to
the
the previous losses we've had and it
depends on the backdrop you know that
there's been
some data on this you know who fares
better in a breakup i mean i don't
my
anecdotal women men versus women you
mean yeah i mean i don't know that i
want to go there but not for political
correctness reasons but i don't know how
good the data are what i will say this
is the person who is able to feel
the intense sadness um and maybe anger
and maybe also
love and maybe also regret and maybe
also shame and maybe also anger the
person who can get closest to the real
feelings will move through it more
quickly if there's one thing that's
absolutely true about breakups and
trauma generally is that all good forms
effective forms of moving through trauma
and challenge involve feeling one's
feelings
and not
sublimating them into more work or
sublimating them into anger or
sublimating them into finding a new
partner too quickly right reality is the
person who confronts the reality
and the feelings
more frequently and in more depth at the
breakup is the person who is going to
emerge from it more quickly
but there's no doubt in my mind about
that and there are some studies that
kind of speak to that i think that does
this mean
like taking two weeks off from work just
to mourn the relationship maybe but the
challenge is one also has to be a
functional person during the course of a
breakup and so this there are there is a
time to kind of pack it down go to work
pack it down tend to be other people
that need you pack it down continue to
invest in oneself and health and whatnot
but i think that people who mask
um challenge of any kind but especially
psychological challenge
with substances or distraction
inevitably those people fare worse and
uh and nowadays it's much harder i think
that the breakups involve um access to
the person like when i was growing up
you broke up and you had a home phone
and that was it yeah and maybe a friend
i remember this a friend saying uh like
you know so-and-so is dating and so and
you're like
right now you can see it like that's
things you know now it's like people are
doing their own detective work
yeah so
so the block function and the mute
function is an appropriate healthy um
thing
i believe and yet people's curiosity
about this gets right into you know
there's a whole dimension of like what
is the neuroscience of jealousy and and
that that's uh tricky but i think that
breakups are there they're
they're like deaths if there was if it
was a relationship that one wanted
even if not they're like deaths and they
need to be
looked at and moved through through the
lens of grief and grieving and complex
grief and healthy grief a lot of people
think that grief is like depression the
data show that grief is nothing like
depression
is grief is
anticipation
of
a reward that you know will never be
actualized again and even in saying that
there's like a little bit of a pang
there it's like oh yeah
thirsty it's like being thirsty and the
glass of water is empty and it will
never be full and so you go how do i
deal with that and it's this weird
metabolical way of it actually it's
required to go into that experience
rather than
trying to pretend the glass will
eventually be full again or rather than
we're going and looking for another
glass of water right away
it's weird right you would think it
would be like just distract yourself
move on form a new attachment now that
said some people have a very strong
attachment drive they're very
affiliative
and
for some people
and i'm not suggesting people run out
and like sleep with a bunch of people or
date about but for some people
like getting away from the smells and
reminders of that person can be very
helpful because it's like a it's just
otherwise they're being constantly you
know bask you know getting overwhelmed
with the kind of like subconscious
reminders right right sometimes moving
to a new location is good sure sure you
know
famous people
what's that don't date famous people
there's a good rule out there for people
that
want a healthy relationship which is
if you are somebody who has a
a big following i i don't think that
people with big following
they should sort of set a limit like
find the person who doesn't have an
instagram account or something you know
i'm just joking um
you know
but i do think that the ability to to do
detective work yeah yeah or on people
that we're now are trying to move away
from yeah it's very toxic
are we what is the real purpose like
what's the biology of finding someone
and i'm very curious of whether or not
that's like um a pattern in our
in our reality that is flawed and that
this sort of eternal seeking for the one
is just
is is um cause causes a lot of pain and
frustration and because it's always
looked at that a failure and an ending
is a failure
and
um i i'm curious what the real if there
is a biological reason why you should
find one person
well that's a okay so i can't answer
this with any certainty and um you know
it's it i'm sort of half smiling because
these days that there's a lot of
interest in whether or not you know
this is going to be modified over time
uh as as social structures change and
legal structures change i mean there are
legal incentives for monogamous
yeah marriage right like tax incentives
and there are people who will say oh
well you kind of write that back to the
history of it and this was designed for
this reason or that reason um i had a
guest on the podcast maybe you're aware
of him or talked to him david buss who's
a professor at um
university of texas austin who's written
he's an evolutionary psychologist he's
one of the luminaries and founders of
that field and
i asked him um as i said you know a
number of people that i know
are talking more and more about and i
have some friends who are actually in um
so-called uh open relationships or
polyamorous relationships like that's
not my proclivity but that's right
that's that's what they're in and yeah
why is it indifferent and sometimes it's
symmetric like they both see other
people sometimes asymmetric like just he
or she sees other people in any event
and he said you know that there's been a
growing trend in recent years the
research says toward people
rewriting um some of the rules of
typical rules of relationship in order
to um
in order to counter these fear of loss
and and um oh and break up and yet
having to deal with some of the more
primitive aspects of our wiring like
jealousy right i mean um i think
uh people still people in those
relationship arrangements still get
jealous and actually sometimes the
jealousy is the fuel for the renewing
this is kind of like there sounds like a
fun loop
yeah yeah not to me but it but i think
to some people no i realized you were
being as i realized you were being
sarcastic but it's interesting so why
the one well i think that human
relationships and pair bonding as it
were so here we're talking about the
more typical scenario is monogamous
relationship um
maybe even monogamous marriage right um
is
certainly the most typical
and we do write stories about that from
the time we're very young you hear about
like princess and prince and you hear it
oh gosh yeah i mean my little girls are
like when are you going to get married
and have babies i'm like i don't know
right so there's a scripting of the
story right and nowadays i think there
is a lot more room around like i know a
number of very very happy amazing
couples that don't have kids
um they do have dogs just saying um but
they but they have they seem very happy
and they've chosen not to have children
i know people who have lots of children
seem to just want more and more and
that's where they
they thrive i think that um
there is a
whatever the story is in one's mind
about what success represents in
relationship
will be the driver of whether or not
these chemical systems are activated to
a greater or lesser degree so for
instance if someone really wants
marriage and children
they can tell like deep down and they
tell they can tell themselves all day
that you know they're okay with the fact
that their partner doesn't want kids but
at the end but the reality is they're
always going to feel a little bit
underwhelmed by their own experience
unless they do that cognitive remapping
to go okay well got all these other
things right so the power of decision
making
is strong but it's not infinite the
power of understanding a mechanism or
understanding okay well got all this
although i didn't get that is
powerful but it's not infinite we can't
i i don't believe that we can completely
overcome our deepest wishes for
ourselves i don't um
and that's a maybe we'll depress certain
people but i would hope that it would
serve as kind of a motivator for really
thinking about what those are and you
know for a lot of people
um is getting more psychological but i
think a lot of people actually are not
that in touch with what they want which
frankly
shouldn't surprise us because how can
you know what you want if you've never
actually experienced it before like if
you don't have a very clear narrative
about what it is that
is going to make you happy how in the
world could you seek
the thing that makes you happy with any
right 100 certain an arrow aimed at
anything right and a lot of people will
write the script as well you know we
weren't planning on having a kid but
then it's the best thing ever happened
or you know i never thought i'd end up
with somebody like this but then um i
now i just think about all their amazing
qualities like our ability to reshape
and rationalize in a positive way is is
remarkable but again not infinite and so
i think that the i do believe that the
the
the honest conversation with ourselves
and with other people whether or not in
the context of a friendship or a
therapist or if someone is truly alone
and you know journaling right is
incredibly powerful and you know this
has a has roots in some classic
psychology where people would do empty
chair work it's kind of an old technique
now but that will literally
stand in front of an empty chair just by
themselves no therapist around and have
a conversation with themselves
why would that be useful well some of
the early psychologists realized that
honest conversation with oneself is
prone to all sorts of i like your mind
can get distracted you can it's hard to
third person yourself
um in in your own head right but but if
you if you will see yourself there in
this empty chair that can be
useful in bringing about like wow like
real honesty i think people do all sorts
of things they drink too much they go on
um different types of journeys of
different kinds pharmacologic or others
they think that they the truth is just
gonna kind of emerge and um while i
don't have judgment about those those
pursuits i think that um
it
it's worth people really thinking about
what they truly want i think nowadays
there's um there's almost a shame
associated for it's not a good one but a
shame associated with really defining
with what one wants
uh defining what one wants and really
articulating it because let's be honest
the moment that one is really clear
about what they want is also the moment
in which they
that not getting it becomes
more powerful as a punishment or kind of
lack of dopamine reward so there's a
power in in denial right um anyway this
is getting very psychological
my stance is i really believe that um
human relationships are among the most
incredible source of these
these things because of the learning
that occurs there like i think one of
the the most important pieces of
scientific data that i've ever learned
is from my colleague ali crum who's in
the department of psychology she works
on mindsets
um i think this will resonate
because your mindset is is such a strong
one and i think that she's studied
stress she's studied fitness she's a
clinic a clinical psychologist research
professor at stanford and was a d1
athlete she's an amazing person loved it
you guys should chat at some point i
feel like there would be i want to be a
fly on the wall for that conversation
but they've done experiments where
basically if people take the mindset
that stress grows you or that in a
relationship effort counts or that
stress on a relationship obviously you
don't want to endanger oneself but
that if if you take the mindset stress
grows me
then
outcomes are far better than if people
think that stress will be avoided and it
seems so simple but that mindset is a
very rare one in fact in word studies
they only really saw that mindset
occur reflexively in um
already through seal training operatives
in the seal in the seal community
everyone else everyone else d1 athletes
professional athletes entrepreneurs
students doesn't matter where they went
to school like now stress is bad in any
case i think ally's
dr ali's data are remarkable because
they show that essentially what we
believe about stress and challenge
defines the trajectory of
the relationship to that stressor
challenge and in the context of
relationship if both people and here's
the challenge both people take the
mindset
like we're going to try and make this as
great as possible but should we hit hard
times that's just making us better in a
year yeah they think it's a sign there's
a lot of people that think that stress
or when something goes wrong it's a bad
sign right and and in fact stress is a
chemical cue to the brain that we need
to rewire
and change something and that's an
opportunity for rewiring and i think
that um you know people say challenge is
an opportunity for growth but that like
in the physiology context when the body
is stressed the brain goes
wait a second everything's different
about this environment and whatever
happens now is going to dictate how i'm
going to function in the future if the
brain never gets stressed
why would it ever change it's like it's
doing everything just fine the stress is
a chemical
um
milieu it's like bad weather
that says oh you know we need to patch
the roof
right without that bad weather it's just
these gaping holes are always sitting
there unbeknownst to us
okay well then i'll ask these last two
questions
they kind of go hand in hand and the
first part is just do you know yourself
oh my well i certainly believe that
among the best advice in the world is i
certainly can come up with this is the
oracle know thyself i mean i've
uh i like to think so um i know
i know the feeling states
that i prefer and i like to think that
i've expanded the number and range of
feeling states that i am willing to
experience
and i think that serves me well at this
stage you know
without getting into a lot of backstory
i mean
i mean i've done
i've been in therapy for a very long
time it was actually a requirement of me
being able to stay in school because i
was i was a wild not good teenager
and my life circumstances were
were
challenging less than some more than
others but um
i mean i definitely continue to do my
own personal work um i know my need for
physical exercise and for goal setting
and drive and learning i have a rule i
need i need to do one difficult physical
thing every day and one difficult
mental thing each day oh that's great
what about the sloth day though i
deprive myself of that
of that pursuit both pursuits i just
won't allow it i just want it drives me
crazy but it's what allows me to lean
into it for the other six days of the
week
so i think i know myself pretty well um
i know that i still have blind spots
and i know that um and i know that you
know my way of being uh you know
is uh not for everybody and um
and i'm not concerned about that i think
that that's something that comes with
age i think i'm i'm 46 now and i'll be
47 soon and i i kind of
looked forward to this stage where i
i certainly if i ever offend somebody or
i you know insult them in any way
that would be inadvertent i can assure
you but
um but i would hope they tell me and
then i'd modify my behavior but i no
longer spend any time whatsoever
thinking about whether or not i'm
getting approval or or not from people
or validation that's a freeing place to
be yeah i think that that all people um
should seek to i like to
um untether from the need for validation
i'm happy if people like what i'm doing
i'm not pleased if they don't in the
sense that i especially if they're
people i'm close to i'll try and adjust
i don't really feel much from just sort
of
uh like judgment unless it's given to me
as a
uh like with it with a hey like you
might consider doing it this way instead
uh well the second question i was gonna
ask was gonna be how did you achieve
that do you feel like you answered that
through therapy and time and age
therapy really helps as long as you have
a good rapport with the therapist right
according to paul conte that's the
critical thing report report i have a
good rapport with the therapist and 100
honest disclosure um start to finish um
with self and the other person and and
yes and self care like meaning
um hard physical exercise hard cognitive
work yeah
i think i've had to work at it but the
main one and this is the stinger
is that life experience right i've i've
had a lot of people die i've had
breakups i've had great relationships
i've had
you know you have to live life
as you know like one has to live life
and make mistakes hopefully not fatal
ones um but make mistakes so that you
have the opportunity to learn and then
but try not to make the mistakes twice
so experience and a hell of a lot of
introspection and
well a lot of work basically you have to
care and want it okay well then the last
question is what what is it what
question is it that you most want
answered
like what's the thing that you wake up
thinking about you go to bed you walk
around you look out and you're like man
just really want to know
that's a great question i i concern
myself with
not why questions but how questions
so
i don't spend a lot of time thinking
about whether or not we have free will
or why we're here or not here i have
thoughts about that um
and curiosity about that but i never
wonder why like why me or why are people
so crazy why you know bulldogs so great
i don't ask why questions
um i decided
pretty early stage and still now to
concern myself with how questions i look
at the world and i think where are the
pain points and the opportunities for
growth people are stressed people need
sleep people need to improve their
fitness people need to um move through
relationships break up yeah and i think
like
how how how can we do this better what
are the tools how can we do this better
how can i contribute how can i take my
life and and make my time here useful
for as many people as as possible before
the reaper gets me which inevitably they
will right that's one thing we know for
sure um hopefully david sinclair will
push that number out david's got us all
to 120 right now he tells me that i eat
too much steak and then i'm gonna die by
75. i say 76. there's a lot more people
that die from not eating steak than
eating steak i would argue that too and
i'm half argentine so you know um
but the
i i think that's really where i'm at
these days and and i always was i think
like now and forever i concern myself
with
how can i make
my life count while also enjoying my
day-to-day experience and how can i
take that i've been very blessed right
i've had some challenges in my life but
i've been very blessed
and i want to take what i learn and what
i can find and i want to get it out to
as many people as possible so that they
can benefit and so it's a how how can i
do that better so is that if we distill
it down to a how is it how can i
contribute to society the most the
simple one-line question would be real
close to that it would be
how can i make my life as beneficial to
humanity now and going forward as
possible well that's extremely admirable
it's just it's the way i'm wired i'm
hardwired that way that's why you're
into so many things that's why you have
you talk about attachment but then you
talk about
cold therapy and you talk about like all
the different things because how can you
do that unless you help in so many
different categories and i suppose from
a selfish perspective um
by making it a broad pursuit there's no
way i can achieve that
across the board for everything and
everyone but what that means is that
there's dopamine forever for me
what is it 3500 things that you like at
least 3 500 pet peeves and at least 3
500 loves yeah so
fantastic all right well thank you so
much this was very interesting thanks
for for having me on i realized that i i
talked far more than i listened and i
apologize for that i have a ton of
questions for you but we'll save that
for another time maybe
if we're lucky you'd come on the podcast
and then i can um ask you questions
about you and your experience
fascinating i love it and i love your
show it's it's seriously i
i don't know how much time you spend
putting into your episodes especially
the solos where you're talking about
things but
it's a lot of information in that head
thanks i um it's a lot of prep but i
really enjoy it and um
again i've been doing that since i was a
little kid i used to give lectures in
class on mondays until they really they
stopped me yeah it's it's sort of i have
a bit of a scientific tourette's i sort
of can't help it i love it it's
fantastic i mean i'm on vacation right
now um and i'm in newport beach and like
i just go for a walk for hours and just
listen especially this week i knew i was
talking to you so i listened all week so
i wasn't listening to music when i went
running i was listening to you thanks so
much i i
really appreciate it and i've great
admiration and respect for your
accomplishments and also the fact that
you didn't just take those and stop that
you're clearly on um yet another uh
incredible mission so i look forward to
more discussion on another dopamine hit
you know thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today i
hope you enjoyed it if you like what you
heard today and you want to hear more
please click on the subscribe button